For those who don’t know, Will-o’-the-Wisps,
also called “ignis fatuus,” Latin for
“foolish fire”, are balls of light that
are seen hovering over swamps at night and
look similar to flickering lanterns, with
the light often being blue in color.
Several theories exist as to its cause, including
bioluminescence; that is, the glow is caused
by something natural like fireflies or honey
fungus.
Another, somewhat oddball, theory is that
barn owls might fly over swampy areas and
reflect light from the moon or other sources
off of their white plumage, making it look
like a bobbing lantern.
However, one of the most accepted theories
was more or less discovered by Allesandro
Volta, who discovered methane in 1776.
He believed that lightning mixed with the
swamp gases caused the ghost lights.
His theory was extremely controversial at
the time and often disregarded because of
the unlikeliness of spontaneous combustion
and because the theory did not explain why
Will-o’-the-Wisps appeared to retreat when
approached.
With technological advances, we can prove
Volta’s theory was more or less correct.
Will-o’-the-Wisps are caused by burning
gases—called “swamp gas” or “marsh
gas”—that develops from the breakdown
of organic matter in persistently wet areas.
The movement of the wisps is usually disregarded
and it is explained that the gases disperse
when approached because of the movement in
the air.
The normal decomposition of organic matter
in open air is called “aerobic decomposition.”
Like all organic matter, plants and animals
are largely made up of carbon, hydrogen, and
oxygen.
When decaying in the presence of oxygen, the
by-products of the decomposition are water,
carbon dioxide, and energy, or heat.
In swampy or marshy areas, aerobic decomposition
is often unable to take place.
Instead, the dead matter is buried beneath
water and saturated soil where it continues
to decompose in the absence of air.
The matter is broken down by anaerobic bacteria,
the by-products of which are methane, carbon
dioxide, nitrogen, phosphines, and other chemicals.
It is believed that, as the gases rise from
the soil and water and escape into the atmosphere,
the methane mixes with the phosphines and
creates the blue lights seen hovering over
the swamps.
Phosphines are flammable, toxic gasses that
can burst into spontaneous flame in the presence
of air.
As it burns, it produces a dense white cloud,
which could give the flame more substance.
Mixed with methane, the effect is the Will-o’-the-Wisps
that inspired so many stories.
The name “Will O’ the Wisps” has a similar
meaning to “Jack O’ Lantern” (“man
of the lantern”).
In this case, coming from the definition for
“wisp” (bundle of sticks or straw used
for a torch), thus “Will of the Torch”.
In this case, one of the principle legends
behind the name concerns Will Smith… no,
not that Will Smith, but rather a guy named
Will who was a particularly evil blacksmith.
There are a variety of versions of this legend,
but the basic idea is that when he died and
attempted to get into Heaven, Saint Peter
gives him a second chance at life, but he
blows it and ends up being doomed to walk
the Earth forever, not unlike the Irish legend
of Stingy Jack.
Also like the Jack O’ Lantern legend, the
Devil gives Smith an ever burning lump of
coal to use as a light.
But in this case, it is also to keep Smith
warm in cold, damp places
like marshes.